recording in progress
we're live on LinkedIn live and on
YouTube live
and we're here with professor
from SP Jane School of Global Management
and
hi
um let me
bring up our
loving our presentation my name is
Stuart Creek I'm with simply learn we're
the delivery partner with SP Jane School
of Global Management for the
professional certification in product
management we'll be talking today
um the agenda
a little bit about SP Jane about simply
learn and
mainly about product management as a
central career field for you or as an
extension to your existing career
we'll talk about what this program
offers and how it gets you Future Ready
in the field of product management
and then we'll talk about enrollment
steps and we'll take your questions
um Professor if you
'd like to introduce yourself in the
school
sure
thank you Stuart and welcome to the
participants for this session uh it's
it's nice to be here with all of you and
my name is selvan and I am the program
director for this particular program
with SP Jane uh I come with 35 years of
Industry experience half of it has been
in the business
started as a salesperson and was leading
a global profit and loss of a business
unit
and half my career has been in HR space
so to be lucky to be having both the
dimensions of business and the people so
I'm going to be the program director and
this program was structured by me and
it's a pleasure to be presenting about
this program I'll be anchoring about
four or five sessions in the cohorts
that are planned in the upcoming cohorts
so that's my background and
to give you a brief introduction about
SP Jane
and uh SP Jane as all of you know needs
no introduction it's a global business
school and uh it is uh accredited in
Australia so uh started in Dubai and
then migrated to Singapore Sydney and
Mumbai and a recent campus is in London
and uh the next one is planned in
Chicago so this is a global school
which offers
undergraduate and postgraduate programs
the programs are well known because it's
a multi-city
uh sort of a program that they do if
it's for example an MBA then you start
in Singapore you go to Mumbai and then
you finish in Dubai so that's how the
program works so uh you get exposure to
many countries uh many cultures so and
it's highly ranked across the globe by
many of the best Forbes or times or any
of the ratings have been very good for
spgn which I think most of you are aware
uh if you can move to the next slide
these are visuals of some of our
campuses that you can see
and they are all quite well accomplished
campuses and one of the unique things
that we do is that there is high level
of interactivity in our MBA programs
across these campuses so that it gives
you sort of a live experience
irrespective of which city you are
learning so the technology has matured
to that level where wherever you are it
gives you a sort of a global experience
and we can just go on to the next one
these are some of the
recognitions for the school it's ranked
as top 20 in the world by Forbes top 100
by The Economist uh it's the number one
in Dubai number one in UAE top 100 in
the world by Financial time so number
four by Times Higher Education so I
think there is enough of recognition in
terms of the quality of Education that
we provide and that's what we bring to
the table as far as this particular
program is concerned
the key success has been because of this
particular aspect called as bracket
emissions basically our faculty come
from diverse Business Schools have a due
Cornell so
most of them are phds and they have
extensive experience not only teaching
but they are also rich in terms of
corporate exposure like for example I
come with about 35 years of corporate
exposure so many of us are called as
practitioners because we have a
combination of academic orientation and
practical sort of exposure and our
faculty come from across continents and
uh the most of them are research focused
with a number of textbooks articles
behind their career so and we take
student evaluation very seriously and
focus a lot on how the students are
looking at our programs
so with that I will want to hand over to
Simply learn to talk about simply learn
as an organization and what they bring
to the table so thanks thank you solven
um
simply learn is the world's number one
online boot camp we
developed a methodology for delivering a
boot camp style of Education Without
requiring you to travel to some
classroom and lock yourself into that
classroom for two three four weeks at a
time for high intensity learning instead
we deliver that high intensity learning
on an online platform that's accessible
to you no matter where you are
this allows you to take live courses
from faculty like the SP Jane faculty
um
and do your classwork your homework and
your projects in between live classes on
any schedule that you choose so you have
a platform that's available to you
24x7 and it allows you to do all of that
work on your own schedule
uh we have learners
uh you know others simply learn programs
across 400 of the Fortune 500 and our
company has offices the UK Singapore and
of course in Bangalore where we're
headquartered
um we focus on digital skills
we partner with organizations like spj
and with other universities
to make our platform available for them
to offer their curriculum and their
programs on their worldwide basis so
that's our role in this
and
the point you can talk solving about the
role of product management
important business function and as a
career field
like to go oh you're on mute I'm sorry
yeah I hope you can see me now yes
okay so let me talk a bit about product
management and it's the program that we
are doing with simply learn and uh
product management is a sort of a
holistic sort of an approach because if
you would have seen a typical b-school
they focus primarily on sales marketing
or HR or Finance so you'll find that
sort of streams but in the business
context what happens is the product
becomes the center of focus and all
these are surrounded by that particular
product so whether it is the customer
the market the pricing the financial
aspects the profitability you name it
the user experience all of that is
around the product so what happens is
product management gives a sort of a
holistic approach to the management and
very few b-schools teach this as a sort
of a integrated subject but the demand
for this particular fashion is extremely
high because the product makes a company
successful or failure so all
organizations know that they have to
have the best of product managers to
make themselves successful but getting
that expertise in the market is very
very tough because every person comes
with a particular amount of
specialization but not a holistic view
that's where product management is a
subject which is of high demand
currently and only few Institute which
which can deliver that sort of a
holistic experience are able to provide
that to the students
and at the same time uh it is like
developing T skills T skills is
basically that you get a broad knowledge
of a variety of skills and a depth
knowledge in a particular skill so in
product management what we are trying to
focus for you is depending on the area
of expertise that you bring in because
you might be a salesperson you might be
a marketing person you might be already
a product management person you might be
a finance person so you can continue to
specialize in that area but in product
management you develop the broad skills
of all the other subjects so that you
can fit in as a successful product
manager so that's where product
management as a subject is becoming
extremely important for now and this
particular visual on the right talks
exactly what I was talking to you that
it's the aggregation of everything
whether it is marketing Finance
customers Channel and a legal sales as a
product manager you should know
everything but at the same time you
should have expertise in one area which
is where you are coming from with your
experience or you will develop over
period of time what is that going to be
can be data it can be AI it can be sales
it can be anything but that's your depth
of knowledge and you you top it up with
all these sort of uh the t-shaped broad
knowledge
so
the focus starts with understanding the
customer and that's where we emphasize
on start with the customer and explain
to you why you need to build this
particular product who's going to be the
customer how is the customer going to uh
the buying Behavior behind the customer
what is the right price that you want to
have for that particular
product how does it fit into the overall
strategy of your organization how do you
do the road mapping for your product for
the next few years a variety of subjects
are covered which you will find is very
very interesting and at the same time
because of the nature of the faculty
that I talked to you about they will be
bringing a lot of insights for you a lot
of practical examples uh trying to help
you understand what is product
management all about so that's going to
be the key learning for you and uh if we
can go to the next slide
we lost the slide Stuart
my apologies we uh
there's an internet issue here so I got
kicked out for a second
okay so we are back here and if we can
move to the next slide
so this shows you what are all the
skills that you will require and these
are all covered in the course that we
are talking about starting with strategy
Innovation ideation design thinking uh
what is an MVP what is the Persona
what's the user Behavior developing a
product roadmap uh what are the features
that one should incorporate what you
should avoid uh the entire life cycle
management and how do you Market it so
the the coverage is quite comprehensive
and there are a few tools also that are
used in project management product
management and project management uh
that will be
covered as part of this so not only that
but it also touches upon the softer side
of product management which is basically
around the leadership mindset that is
required and those dimensions are also
covered as part of this particular
course I think there are few people who
are wanting to ask questions I do not
know Stuart you do you want to take
questions at the end or do they key it
in or I saw someone asking can I ask
some questions
yeah we would prefer to take the
questions at the end but if you see
something that somebody asked in the
chat that you feel you want to address
you're allowed to do that
um the best advice to our guests our
webinar attendees today put your
questions into the Q a function within
um
Zoom if you are watching on a streaming
service put your questions into the chat
or comment function on your streaming
service
you should have somebody who is able to
transfer those over to me and then when
we reach the Q a part of our
presentation we'll take those questions
at this point
I would like to ask a poll question of
the audience
and this poll question is what has
prevented you from up to this point from
joining a program of this type
is it because you can't find a program
that has a comprehensive curriculum as
Sullivan described is it because you
don't think you'd get the practical
experience from the program that would
make you job ready is it because
learning from pre-recorded videos is not
your preferred learning style or is it
because your work schedule is
too tight to give you the time for
learning
I'll leave this question open for a
little bit longer as the answers
continue to come in
foreign
give you about another 10 seconds to get
your answers in
we'll close the poll in about five
seconds from now
all right
and
the number one concern from people who
responded is that you don't think you
would get the Practical exposure
the Practical experience that you would
need in order to be able to show off
your new skills to a potential employer
or to your current employer and then
close after that are not being able to
find a comprehensive curriculum or not
having enough time in your work schedule
so
we'll talk a little bit about that
and
yeah
so
[Music]
yeah should I go ahead
yes please yes sure so I think what I
explained to you was that some of the
faculty are people who have a lot of
Industry experience so you can be rest
assured that a lot of practical exposure
in fact you will have to try out a few
things when you are learning and see
that you are able to do it yourself so
those things are all integrated into
this particular program and typically
the program happens on a weekend so that
you don't it won't impact your work
schedule on a week date so that's how it
is structured and I think it is quite
comprehensively designed in terms of
there are 14 modules which we will talk
to you about and this is live sessions
it's not pre-recorded videos that you
will be going through in this particular
program that's one big difference you
get to interact with the faculty live
listen to to them ask questions so it's
as good as being in a class it's not a
recorded session that you will be going
through and there are going to be a lot
of assignments quizzes practical
learning will be there part of it so I
think that way this program
would possibly address many of the
concerns that you brought out in the
poll so you can get rest assured about
that so it's about three hours of
teaching that we would be doing and
it's an investment of another two to
three hours every week that you have to
do offline at your convenience so that
you're able to get the maximum benefit
out of this particular program
so we can move to the next slide
so
basically it's a spjn program it leads
to a professional certification so at
the end of it you get a certification of
completion uh there are a lot of real
world case studies from Harvard
and online sessions will be there from
Experts of VMware or Amazon Adobe and
Microsoft and there is a short Capstone
project at the end of this where you
will be asked to work on a particular
topic and then submit it and it also
leads to an executive alumni membership
status for spj
and which entitles you to further
discounts in future programs that's what
you get as part of this
uh you you need not be someone who knows
product management who has worked in
product management uh as long as you
have a keen interest to learn I think we
are keen and two years of experience is
something that we are insisting on
because once you have that experience in
any particular area it gives you that
Foundation what I talked to you about
the T skills where you know something
and then we can build on your other
skills to make you as a product manager
so that's the criteria that we are
looking for
screw it and then we'll run the next
poll here just out of curiosity how much
experience do you have
here we go
and we'll leave this open for about 30
seconds
okay and the numbers are slowing down so
we'll give you another 10 seconds
and get your answers in
and here is the result
so
more than half the audience has more
than three years of experience we have
about a third of the audience who are
still in um
college or university
so
it looks like for the two-year
experience requirement
over half of the audience here it meets
that meets that Criterion
Will Go On
and we'll talk about how the program
prepares you
I think so I'll just take few minutes to
explain this particular slide because
this gives you the roadmap for the
entire program and there are several
modules about 14 or 15 modules that you
will see which are all listed down most
of them are three hours duration and it
starts with an orientation which is the
first session which will be for one hour
but other than that almost everything
else will be for three hours and we also
start learning from failures because
that's an important aspect of learning
so while the successful products are
talked about the failure products is
what teaches us a lot of lessons so I
think we start from there why products
fail and then get into the customer side
of it then we start building the product
which is in the subsequent modules and
we create the roadmap for that we get
into the market and see how this will
fit into the market and then put on the
top of that what is the ux and in that
we teach a very interesting topic called
neuro product marketing which is uh from
an Australian Professor who will be
talking to you about
his research on this particular topic
these soft skills like systems thinking
critical thinking and being a change
leader are being taught by a professor
one of our senior most professors based
out of Dubai
uh at the end you also have a few tools
which are going to be expert sessions
which will be taken by some of the
experts who know this particular tool so
if you look at it it's very
comprehensive uh starts from almost
scratch and then takes you right through
the entire life cycle of a product and
also gives you some flavor of certain
tools that are being used in this and
Innovation is going to be one of the key
things that we'll be focusing on how do
you really develop uh innovation in
products and there are going to be some
industry experts also who will be
speaking on this particular area now let
me just briefly tell you about some of
the faculty
who are part of this program they might
come in I talk to you about Dr
Christopher Abraham who's from Dubai who
will be teaching on the uh on the
software aspect takes the leadership
mindset uh
Nicholas is based in Australia and he'll
be teaching you on the neural side of it
might come in for the marketing aspects
professoriation Brahma would be again
touching on the marketing aspects so I
think there are a few more faculty is
that so in the next slide
okay these are the industry uh experts
who will be talking to you from
Microsoft or adobe Amazon and VMware
again these are practicing product
managers who will bring in their
practical experience and explain to you
what is happening in the industry which
is also going to be extremely helpful
for you
so would simply learn uh would you want
to take this
yeah I'll mention uh the eligibility and
prerequisites I think
Dr Sullivan touched on one of them which
is requiring two years of experience
work experience in any field
um the idea here is that
this gives you the background in how
organizations work and what the role of
product management is even if you're not
working in product management you
understand how
products fit into the business World
working in
um you do not have to have a product
management background
role in this program
um
and you do have to have a bachelor's
degree
field
um all of those things
will be evaluated when you submit your
application so this point I want to ask
based on what you've heard so far
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
we'll leave this open for just a short
while
since it's just a yes or no question
um
close it in about five seconds please
get your answers in
and here we go
and a little more than three quarters of
our audience is interested in enrolling
in the program based on what they've
heard so far so
this is a great time to share with you
the process of enrollment
the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
you contact us at ask us simplylearn.net
we will take your information we'll send
you a additional questions you have to
fill out in order to complete your
application
including the documentation of your work
history in your educational history
then we'll review the application
and you will receive an offer of
admission if your application's accepted
putting into the chat right now
the email address as well as the link to
the program page
on our website and
the fees in the program schedule which
are very important for you to know the
next cohort begins on February with
classes starting on March 4th so 2nd of
February is that first induction or
orientation class that you saw in the
curriculum and then the regular classes
start on March 4th
um this program is offered in India and
the rest of the world
um outside the U.S
in India the program fees are one lock
54
875 which is inclusive of taxes
and you can have that financed zero
interest financing for
5141 rupee a month
and in the rest of the world it's
denominated in U.S dollar 2100 US
Dollars
um with financing as low as 175 a month
um also if you are
doing this for your current position
um you can ask your employer about
tuition reimbursement the employers do
have a policy
of
assisting employees with education so
you can ask your employer whether you
have that benefit and again for more
insistent please reach out to us at ask
us at simplylearn.net
and
I just want to ask a follow-up question
here which is for those of you who are
interested how soon would you like to
start you looking to do the cohort that
begins in February
or are you looking at maybe the one
right after
or is this something you want to do
further down the road
I'll leave this open for a bit
numbers come in
foreign
about 10 seconds
right
here's the result
so about 40 percent of the audience
wants to do
um this either in the
February cohort or the one right after
um and the rest of uh respondents say
that they're looking to do this further
down the road uh in either case we
recommend that you contact us at ask us
at simplylearn.net if you're ready to
enroll uh we can get you started with
that if
you are
not quite ready we can keep you in the
loop and make sure that you're informed
about future cohorts and ask answer any
other questions you have about the
program
at this point
I'd like to go to the questions and
answers
to
unshare the screen
but we can take a look at that we have
our number energy here also from simple
learn will help us answer some of those
questions as well
um we have a couple of questions that
came in from our linked audience linked
LinkedIn audience
um you you see
is this a boot camp Ibraham asks is this
boot camp to hire or is this a just a
learn and seek from the job for yourself
um I don't know if you want to answer
that question
thanks to it so um just to answer that
question in a little more in detail this
boot camp is going to give you a lot of
information about what you need to know
in terms of getting or transitioning
into a product management role and there
will be a lot of assistance provided
along with the along with the program in
due course of time while learning but uh
when we specifically talk about
enrolling or getting yourself into a job
there will be assistance provided
particularly we do not provide any kind
any such assistance where we go ahead
and uh provide some kind of material or
some kind of information which talks
about and Assurance but yeah definitely
about how you can land into a job and
what exactly will you be looking forward
to in terms of skills in terms of uh
characteristics in terms of uh
preparation material in terms of
guidance whatever is needed will be
provided or assisted from our side as
part of the program
and so to be clear this is a job
assistance are that aspect of the
program is job assistance to help you uh
organize and conduct and prepare for
your job search but it is not a job
guarantee so you still have to go
use those tools and search for the job
on your
um
Let's see we have a question from Ashwin
on the LinkedIn audience who says is uh
a proposed product management framework
um is this applicable if your goal is to
take internal I.T or business services
and convert them to B2B project products
for example
um I've seen personally I've seen
examples from uh
major companies that developed
I.T tools for managing their remote
workers and then turn those I.T tools
into a software as a service product so
uh Sullivan if you could
comment on that is this uh would
students of this program Learners should
get the insights into that process sure
so uh see this particular course is
going to give you an exposure to a lot
of uh tools techniques Frameworks where
it will touch upon a variety of
Industries and scenarios when I say
Industries it might be about automobile
it might be about white goods it might
be about I.T so it will touch upon
everything and at the same time it will
also touch upon a variety of scenarios
some of it what you explained like our
service can be converted into a into a
framework or a product and can be
positioned as a service so I think it
covers all of that but if you're looking
that whether it is going to give you a
deep dive expertise on one specific area
that is something which you have to
pursue based on the knowledge that you
gain because you should appreciate in a
cohort of about 60 odd students there
will be a participants from different
areas some coming from Finance
background some coming from let's say
manufacturing companies and all so the
product management course will cover in
a sort of cross functional cross
industry sort of an area how to apply
and it will not be only focused on it
while there is going to be like for
example Professor sirish who you saw is
a in-depth product manager with an I.T
exposure a lot of doubts which you can
ask with him online and offline to
clarify but from a subject point of view
it will cover across the industry
sure
thank you for that and we had a question
from uh
Vijay who asks about the roles and
responsibilities of a product manager
um sure very interesting question uh so
uh one thing what you have to be aware
of is that in most companies today
product manager does not have direct
reportees so they it's the job of
leveraging different people with
different experts and therefore the role
is very clearly that the success of the
product in terms of the metrics that are
defined for that particular product
success is owned by the product manager
but it is shared with a lot of people
who have accountability into different
people so it's a very very tough but
interesting job which is why it's a
premium sort of a position to be as a
product manager because you don't have
control over the people on the resources
but at the same time you are accountable
for the success of that particular
product and the organization is come
completely relying on you and your
expertise to make it successful so
that's where you you have to have all
the skills to ensure that you are able
to make that particular product or a
service successful so it's it's a great
position to be in is what I would say uh
enviable but at the same time very
challenging
and
Vijay also asks if someone's not a
domain expert
um is it still valuable to take up
product management
as a generalist
yeah it's again a good question so the
the concepts the principles the tools
techniques Frameworks are generic across
uh domains so you don't have to be
worrying whether you have a specific
domain expertise at this point of time
but once you complete this course and
you take on a role as a product manager
my suggestion to you would be that you
continue to pursue your uh in one
particular domain or in adjacent domains
so that you are seen as a specialist
product manager in that particular
domain so to do this course you don't
have to be a domain expert but once you
finish and you get into a role I would
suggest don't go across domains but go
into one domain deep which will take you
in a fast track in your career
thank you
um
we have a question from ritesh who said
I think that uh our knob you want to
take this one in what if one does not
have a bachelor's degree but has 25
years of work experience
so
um yeah so that's a tricky one but um as
we clearly mentioned as uh as a
prerequisite to be enrolled for this
program one of the key aspects of
getting an understanding of what exactly
we want and we expect and the kind of
audience that we plan to theater do the
bachelor's degree is something that we
consider and we wish to keep as amended
because considering the kind of
expertise and skills that people will
look forward to one as part of the
program while in due course of time
while running as part of the program
will be essentially backed up with a lot
of uh knowledge and a lot of information
that one will be able to absorb and
successfully understand uh with the
association of Association of a
bachelor's degree so hence the
importance of the degree Associated uh
as a prerequisite to the environment
um Meyer asks uh pursuing engineering
right now is he eligible to join this
program it's often
is someone with an engineering position
who's pursuing engineering at this point
of time is it the person so since it is
mentioned very clearly as a bachelor's
degree I'm just talking on your behalf I
think completion of the undergraduation
is important and once that person
completes we might take the person on
board but if let's say the person has
done the final semester and is just
awaiting results then it is good to
apply and on a case-to-case basis uh the
simply learned team will take a call on
that particular situation if it is a
long duration in the if the because our
program is stretched over a period of
time and so it can be on a case to case
basis if the person has just given the
final exams yeah with respect to coming
into this from the engineering field
is this a good fit
yes it is a good fit though I would not
say that it gives any specific Advantage
whether you are an engineer or an MBA
with a you know a psychological
psychology background also it's again a
great fit so I don't think engineering
gives anything as additional Advantage
it gives a good knowledge foundation for
you as an engineer to be able to
appreciate uh a lot from the sort of
Frameworks and the tools that are being
taught but I would encourage that others
are equally on the same footing anyone
who has a degree and with two years of
experience would be able to appreciate
and understand product management and
have a good future in this particular
career
thank you
um
so pallavi asks if this is online or a
combination of online in person and
certainly it is the completely online
program delivered entirely online which
means it's something yeah it's online
program and the only thing is it's live
online program so it's not a program
which is recorded and then viewed but
you will be able to interact directly
with the faculty and ask questions so
it's a live online program
and
a darshan index is interesting question
Arnav um if he enrolls will his status
be updated in the office portal in other
words does he get reminders and that
type of thing
Microsoft's office calendar
uh well this is an interesting one uh
though we haven't seen such kind of an
integration that uh we've come across in
the past but nonetheless I'm happy to
Deep dive and share an update if I am
understanding the question correctly
what uh is inferred is Will and
involvement be triggered to the
Microsoft Office portal of the
individual learner who is involved for
the program uh the direct answer to that
is no but happy to Deep dive and
understand if there's any specific yeah
that the lover is expecting to elaborate
on as of now uh as per the structure of
the program every individual user is
assigned with an LMS portal wherein they
can log in with unique credentials and
get access to live classes which will be
delivered by uh spj global factor and
and that particular token itself serves
as a One-Stop solution to all the
material in terms of content in terms of
any kind of information
more understanding as to what exactly uh
is uh the integration referring to and
probably can get more clarity
is it possible for a person working as a
project
or especially in construction and they
shift into product
trip
yeah okay again a great question a lot
of project managers have shifted into
product management because project
management is a subset of product
management it covers certain aspects
about cost resources time and quality
which are essential components of
product and so if you have a foundation
in project management you have the depth
of knowledge around these four areas
which is around cost quality the time
and so the functionalities so I think
that way it's a it's a good foundation
that you're having so you are going to
make a good journey as far as a product
manager is concerned okay and
we have a question about average salary
why not do you have a insight to that
average salary of products
yeah so
um average uh compensation in the Indian
subcontinent ranges anywhere between
13 to 17 lakhs per annum but again uh so
this is a number that is uh speculative
and you can get a lot of information
that varies within this range
[Music]
and the right piece of information is
something that you'll be able to get
when you get a chance to explore a much
more bigger quantitative number and you
can refer to direct sites like Glassdoor
ambition boards that give a lot of
information around the kind of
experience a product manager has and
related to that the kind of compensation
he or she draws so I would say one of
the aspects that also one should look
into is the kind of experience that he
or she brings into the field and
compared to the person who is just
transitioning to become a product
manager and kind of compensation so uh
having said that uh uh it is a little
speculative to conclude what is the
average uh compensation for uh product
manager on a yearly basis but yes uh a
ballpark would be anywhere between 13 to
70 likes
um
there's a question what is the average
batch size
yeah so 60 is the sort of bad size that
uh spj targets and it can be plus or
minus 5 normally 60 65 is the batch size
that we are comfortable handling a
faculty from spj is comfortable handling
that sort of a bad size okay
and so I'll ask another question which
is uh is the aspect of agile in product
management
the same as it is in project management
yeah the concept of agile is the same
and how it is applied in product
management might be the application is
slightly different from how it is
applied in the project environment the
concept of how you are going to be
having a Sprint and how you are having
the user stories and all those things to
remain the same so you will be touching
upon agile as part of these sessions
that we are doing in this particular
course and that's quite fundamental
product management as well
Palazzi asks if the peas are uh I'm
sorry uh probably asked if the fees are
due all at once or do is there an
installment election and uh as it showed
on the slide you do have the option of
doing installment payments
um we offer um
zero cost financing for that and so
again we can share that uh
with you but uh
the other question that came in was how
to contact us for more questions and
clear any doubts and I would say the
best way to do that is to contact ask us
at simplylearn.net although you have an
email that will come to me which is uh
believe it's Stuart at simply learn is
the
uh invitation you received
um so you can respond to that email
address but the best one is ask us at
simplylearn.net that will get you to a
lending consultant to clear your doubts
and what I'll do here is
uh briefly share this
slide again on the program fees
just so you can see the financing
options
so again
um
the
financing option in India
uh outside of India a 175 US dollars a
month
sure
all right
I'm back
hey sorry about that we had the same
internet issue here
um so that basically concludes the
question and answers
and
um Sultan we did have one person who
asked if they would be able to access a
recording of one of the classes to see
what it looks like but
um if that's something you want to share
please let us know and we can
send a link out to that in the follow-up
email we will be sending a link to the
recording of this session to our
attendees so you'll be able to review
this information
and
with that I want to ask one last
question
of our audience
this is basically
do you require assistance from us
enrolling so
leave that open for a moment
about another 20 seconds
okay
I'm going to end the poll now
and about half of the respondents said
yes I'd like assistance the best way to
do that of course
is to contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
our learning Consultants will be able to
help you with
thank you
answering those doubts and I'm going to
put that link into the chat again for
you
for your convenience
and at this point I'd like to thank
Dr Sullivan for being here with us today
and uh
sharing so generously of your time and
knowledge about this program and about
product management as a field
my pleasure okay uh thank you also arnab
for being here to help with the
information about the program
absolutely thank you so much thank you
Dr Selvin yeah thank you thank you
everyone thank you everyone yes thank
you uh everyone who's in attendance both
on zoom and uh on our streaming services
we want to thank you very much for
attending today and we hope we can
welcome you into the spgn learning
community
um again contact us at ask us at
simplywin.net and we can help you uh get
organized and get started if that's what
you want to do so
at this point that concludes our webinar
for today
thank you bye good night thank you so
much good night